we saw it in the United States where a
historical event is underway former
president Donald Trump is set to appear
in a Miami Court in the coming hours he
faces 37 federal charges in connection
with his handling of classified
documents he's the first former
president to be criminally indicted Alan
Fisher begins our coverage from Miami
in a city which often prepares for
coming storms Miami is cranking up
security around the federal courthouse
has been increasing throughout the day
all agencies getting ready for the
historic first court appearance of a
former U.S president on federal charges
we're taking this uh this event
extremely serious we know that there is
a potential of things
taking a turn for the worst but that's
not the Miami way Donald Trump landed in
Florida in the late afternoon met by a
small group of supporters and protesters
I believe now if he's back to the White
House he's gonna be even better
president he's staying at his Doral Golf
Resort a 30-minute ride from the court
where he'll surrender to the authorities
on Tuesday once he arrives at the court
he will be officially photographed and
fingerprinted it's a federal court there
will be no pictures of him before the
judge he'll then hear details of the 37
charges they include violations of the
Espionage Act obstruction of justice
making false statements and conspiracy
in a series of social media posts Trump
again claimed the prosecution was
political a point he made at rallies
over the weekend and I never thought
such a thing could happen to America
as far as the joke of an indictment it's
a horrible thing it's a horrible thing
for this country
I mean the only good thing about it is
it's driven my poll numbers way up can
you believe this well
Miami's Republican mayor refused to get
involved in the politics just urging
protesters to be peaceful I'm not here
to talk about politics I'm here my role
as mayor of the city of Miami uh
projecting confidence to our residents
and to the residents of the country that
we're going to be ready for tomorrow the
courts in Miami is known for pushing its
cases through quickly a rocket docket
court is what they call it so while
Trump's team will argue that the
prosecutions are malicious and should be
dismissed there's every possibility the
former president could be on trial here
within six months Alan Fisher Al Jazeera
Miami
and live now to John hendren who's
outside the courthouse in Miami just a
few hours to go John until uh president
Trump's former president Trump's
appearance there set the scene like set
the scene for us there outside the
courtroom how has Miami prepared for
transport appearance
well there are six hours still to go
fully so there's a long time for people
to gather today what we're seeing right
now is a group with shirts on it that
say blacks for Trump they are out here
there's also been somebody dressed in a
prison outfit with a ball and chain
saying uh lock him up so we are likely
to have more people out here sort of
choosing their sides not so many six
hours ahead of time but the police say
that they have this town under control
both inside and outside of that
courthouse and there are some
extraordinary procedures Trump could
enter underground we might not even see
him entering the building and then from
there it's likely to be a procedure much
like we saw in the indictment in New
York although this of course is a
Federal indictment and as you heard Alan
say there that means there are no
pictures inside we won't be able to see
the former president inside or hear his
plea for those of us who are not in that
room but uh Trump will come here at
three o'clock local time little for six
hours from now and he will issue his
plea we're told that plea is not guilty
and he has already been campaigning and
fundraising on this indictment
and and yeah we were going to talk about
the legal aspects now about what we can
expect today he president former
president Trump has of course continued
to strike a defying tone saying that the
Biden Administration is weaponizing law
enforcement agencies against him what
will be his strategy here going forward
well that's the pr line the president
has been taking this is selective uh
punishment selective prosecution and
that is an argument that he can make in
court and I think in order for him to
maintain that PR line it's likely that
his lawyers will do that but there's a
very very high bar this is a very
different case than when Hillary Clinton
was investigated for deleting emails on
her personal server that had some
National Security content on it it's
very different from the President Biden
case in which some documents were found
in a couple of locations but his people
immediately turned those documents over
here we're talking about accusations of
obstruction uh of lying to Federal
officials so the selective prosecution
line is not likely to get him very far
we have heard him argue that he can
declassify documents just by thinking
about them but we have a tape here
according to prosecutors in which he
acknowledges while holding a a document
that he says is Secret that he does not
have the power to declassify it so he's
already undermined himself on that
argument
um there are a number of other arguments
that he could take but I mean
essentially what he argues outside of
Court may not have anything to do with
what he argues in court traditionally he
has been making a completely different
case outside of Court than what his
lawyers have been making in court they
have to follow the legal Doctrine
they'll be trying to argue that these
these were not documents that Trump
should not have had that he had some
right to them perhaps that he
Declassified them and what other
arguments they make we're just going to
have to see because he's got very few
Avenues to go down to get out of these
37 counts uh 38 if you include the count
against his alleged co-conspirator but
this is all likely to last beyond the
next election so you can expect to hear
him campaigning vonnet for at least a
year to go and we will closely follow
events there in Miami with you
throughout the day John hendren thank
you very much for the moment
earlier I spoke to Greg Swenson who's
the chairman of Republicans overseas UK
he says Donald Trump is being singled
out while some former presidents have
done a lot worse
I think it's clear that the president
has made some mistakes and and perhaps
you know didn't behave perfectly during
this process but I think the important
uh distinction it's not just an
indictment of a former president it's an
it's an indictment of the leading
candidate in the Republican primary so
in many ways it's it's really a
destructive intervention into the 2024
election and that's that's a sad day for
America not just for Republicans but I
think America in general if some of what
they're suggesting in the indictment is
true that he was somewhat Cavalier in
conversation now granted he wasn't
talking to a foreign enemy or a spy he
was just doing you know having a
conversation in his office with the
journalists but but still there's you
know there's reasons to to for concern
and I think that should be left up to
the voters at The Ballot Box but what
but by by proceeding with this
indictment what would you really making
it a political situation you know it's
the weaponization of the justice system
um mentioned Joe Biden's problems and
and also if you look at Hillary Clinton
in the email scandal from 2016 it looks
like a two-tiered you know double
standard of applications of the law and
I think that doesn't that really won't
sell well with the American voters